Film Courage: I was reading that a high school
journalism teacher was trying to help her
students decipher Tweets and fake news and
that’s something that five years ago, we
wouldn’t even be having this conversation.
Dr. Ken Atchity, Producer: I have a really
strange theory about this whole thing about
fake news is that…I don’t even know how
to say this because…I think the head honcho
is kind of a break through cultural character
I don’t have any fond feelings for him and
I could go on and on about that.
But he is an eccentric creative person.
He is the most amazing producer I’ve ever
seen in my life and I can’t even imagine
one more powerful than he is.
A few years ago people around the world didn’t
even know who he was.
People in New York new who he was but mostly
in a negative way.
But in today’s world whether you are in
Thailand like I was a few weeks ago or whether
you were in an island off the coast of Samoa
or in Latvia or Estonia or Alabania, you can’t
pick up a paper that doesn’t have the word
“Big Guy” in it.
And his ability to get the media to do what
he wants them to do is almost infinite, it’s
astonishing.
People say “Well he is a liar.”
But the more I hear that over the last few
years the more I start thinking what is really
going on (my wife would hurt me for saying
this) is that he is changing or awakening
us to our strange views of truth.
Because I don’t think he knows this (I don’t
think it’s conscious on his part) but he
instinctively knows that truth is completely
relative.
And if a society decides that it’s not relative
then that is a social decision.
Just like the continent of reasoning saying
“We are going to agree that this is true.”
But he’s saying whatever is true…the only
thing that is true is whatever I am saying
at the moment and that’s the way I look
at it (it’s true) and he’s got a lot of
people that even though some of it sounds
just plain crazy.
But isn’t that the way creative people always
sound at the beginning?
So I’m afraid and kind of excited that we
may be going into a whole new era of post-truth
era.
And no one ever quite answered Pilot’s question
that he asked 2,000 years go “What is truth?”
But I think the world of the head honcho is
a world that is getting closer to answering
that then we’ve ever been before because
what is we decide to just dispense with the
concept of truth?
A lot of things wold change, but they are
already changing because of him and I think
it’s a very strange and troubling situation.
But it’s also kind of exhilarating because
maybe it’s time that we do have a different
view of what truth is and maybe we can learn
something from the whole thing.
So I don’t know if this has anything to
do with our interview but…
Film Courage: Well if we look at writing and
fake news, if we look at [William] Randolph
Hearst, he would stage different events back
in the day where a woman would faint on the
street and they would write about it and it
was part of just generating content.
The thing is we didn’t have the Internet
back then so news would spread as fast and
it wouldn’t create chaos in other countries
and our own and then it turns out it’s not
even true.
Dr. Atchity: Well when we look at what’s
happened here, the American people decided
with their votes one way or the other.
I mean I know it was the electoral college
not the popular vote.
But a lot of Americans voted for a reality
show over somebody who was just a little too
truthful or whatever a little too logical,
a little too much of the continent of reasons.
But they voted for the most entertaining of
the two characters.
They voted for entertainment basically.
And that’s scary.
I mean ultimately these other actors are talking
about running and some of them already have
run and actresses, etc.
The blurring of politics and entertainment
is very dangerous but what if it changes the
world.
But what if it change the world for not only
the worst but changes it for the better.
I mean what is an enlightened guy like George
Clooney becomes president.
Film Courage: That would be nice.
Dr. Atchity: And he gets elected because he
is George Clooney.
He gets elected because he’s an entertainer.
What is a guy like Ronald Reagan becomes president?
Film Courage: He was The Great Communicator
though.
Dr. Atchity: Yes, well he was a great actor,
great communicator.
He didn’t need to write his lines, he knew
how to deliver his lines.
So I think all of that is very interesting
and it’s about how the creative worlds intertwine
with daily existence and you watch the broadcasters
and I try to watch Fox news once and awhile
and I find it very difficult to watch it.
But then when I come back to watch CNN and
MSNBC I realize they must find…I understand
how they feel that is hard to watch because
both sides of the coin are manipulating views
of reality to get messages across.
And that’s what writing is about.
Isn’t that what creativity is all about?
A painter paints something like Rothberg,
who would have thought you could have painted
a painting with no figures in it at all (just
color)?
And that’s the world we are going through.
So it’s kind of like we’re on another
frontier of the human’s mind’s evolution
and we’ll see what happens from it.
I’m afraid that certain things are going
to be gone for good after this presidency.
We may not ever get any candidate who isn’t
a visionary in one way or another.
And the big cheese is a visionary even if
you think his vision is dark, clearly he is
a visionary.
He doesn’t like the way things are and he’s
trying to break them up.
And only when things are broken up can they
be put back together again.
So he’s a spoiler and the world…history
is filled with spoilers.
And huge catastrophes and huge changes for
the better have occurred because of spoilers
and who knows where it’s going.
But I think it’s interesting that the entertainment
world being mixed with the world of reality,
it’s going to make it much more challenging.
And I think the Internet is largely responsible
for that because the first thing if you have
a certain medical condition you instantly
Google.
And the first thing you read you go “Oh
my Gosh!”
I’m going to die or I’m goin to die in
this really bizarre way.
And then you read something else that makes
it look like everybody has this problem and
that it’s not a big issue.
And then you keep reading and you get more
and more confused and you go “Wait a minute?
This isn’t making sense.”
Everything is out there and how do you organize
it?
And faced with that you are facing the issue
of creativity because the creator is the guy
or the girl who looks at things and goes “This
whole thing is a mess.
I’m going to make something spectacular
out of it.
I’m going to make SENSE out of it.”
And I think that is why the world is getting
more and more interesting.
Where it’s going I don’t know?
But it’s going to be interesting.